we have the story from cnn
food is more expensive than it has been
in decades cnn you know a broken clock
right twice a day bad news for american
consumers it's getting more expensive to
dine out and getting more expensive to
eat at home restaurant prices spiked 5.8
percent of the last 12 months ending in
november without seasonal adjustments
the bureau of labor statistics said
friday that's the largest 12-month
increase since the year ended january
1982. and unfortunately for those hoping
to curb spending by turning to home
cooking grocery store prices are also at
record highs they jumped 6.4 percent the
largest 12 month increa
increase since 2008 beef had the most
dramatic increase with a 20.9 spike in
prices
so let me ask you guys something
what do you think
is was was the catalyst for the arab
spring
do you know this one worker who was
having a hard time making ends meet and
because of the government finding him
and regulating him he ended up
committing suicide and his story went
viral
i'm uh yeah that's that's the essence of
what i understood it to be from some of
the stories that i heard but i think tim
you would you'd know a little bit more
about this yes i got the name wrong
earlier it was muhammad wazizi that's
about i'm saying that wrong was these
members was easy was easy yeah he uh he
immolated himself
um he was trying to i believe what
happened was he was trying to sell fruit
he was born in uh 29th of march 1984 and
he kept getting the government kept
interfering with his ability to to make
a living and eventually he couldn't so
he just went in front of a government
building and dumped fuel on himself and
immolated himself and this sparked the
the protests in tunisia which started
swooping across these other uh you know
other parts of the the arab world
resulting as many believe in the arab
spring
uh there were some experts who reviewed
why it reached the point where people
were willing to overthrow their
government and there were a few key
factors one of which was
inflation
yes unemployment the price of food yeah
so people could no longer afford to eat
what happens when someone can't eat oh
they get crazy do people just say well i
got no food so i guess i'll just lay
down here and die well i mean they do
have ramadan
fasting is good for you it's okay i'm
muslim i can make these jokes
yeah there's something different about
you know choosing because when you
choose to fast you're in control and you
know you're in control right and you
know the food's waiting for you yeah you
don't know exactly when oh totally get
it but you can prep your body too like
the day before you load up on whatever
you need for the week yeah overnight or
whatever yeah and you fast from sunrise
to sunset and no water
but people drive fast
people often say especially the super
chats here they tell me that you know
one of the things i'm you know they oh i
would love to stand up and talk about
these issues but i have to make sure my
kids have food so the wager right now
among many of these people is that by
complying with the tyranny and what what
they're doing with mass spending and you
know everything's burning the system
down their kids will eat for a longer
period of time than if they were to
stand up and speak up because then their
kids they could get fired and they can't
get food for their kids
i think what i think what drives people
towards you know
revolt and conflict in crisis in a
country civil war even they can't feed
their kids yeah and it's it's partly
about themselves i mean what is the
first thing i mean the first things is
like food on the table
roof over your head
and
what a place to sleep
or something like that i think it's
what's that order i think it's a safety
i think it's i think it's food shelter
and safety yeah security like um the
things that cause massive stress right
if you can't eat your pantry obviously
the first one is safety but i'm just
saying in terms of like food people no
no
yeah maybe we're complaining things but
i meant like the the usually the goal
like when you're trying to provide for
your family the first thing you always
go for is food on the table
you can't provide food on the table yeah
then there you got nothing yeah you're
screwed but at least you have a table
but then if you have no table now you're
cold you're scared and then there's
there's violence or the police are
threatening you you have no safety
people just finally snap and and there's
stories coming out of germany where
people killed themselves because of the
lockdowns and the vax mandates their
stories of a person lighting themselves
on fire killing themselves in australia
because of the lockdowns because of the
vaccine mandates so these stories are
already happening and i think they're
only going to be exacerbated especially
here in the united states where
americans are already dealing with some
of the highest inflation in over 40
years joe biden just gave an extra 20
billion dollars for the defense budget
and there's a clear there's a clear sign
that when the government gets involved
almost every step of the way they are
making this situation that much worse
and i think financially socially when
people are going to see the larger
effects of this as they are already
seeing the largest transfer of wealth in
recorded human history it's going to hit
them hard it's already hitting them hard
but this is only the beginning of this
major wave coming our way that was
produced by government and i don't think
there's any escaping it i don't think
there's any uh life raft we might be
able to if we develop fusion power and
like central decentralized power sources
and then the powerful people just keep
the technology for themselves and don't
release it to the general public and
then hide it from everyone else just
like free energy that would be a problem
then we would still see a crash of the
system yes i think the system could
find some sort of resilience if we can
decentralize our power sources
other than energy yeah but you know
what's what what happened when biden got
into office the administration basically
stripped the us of energy independence
not that i'm saying petroleum energy
independence is necessarily what you're
volume's heavy that's the problem with
it but it is extremely energy dense so
america was we were in that exporter of
oil that's crazy right we were and now
biden's like nordstrom 2. go ahead
russia you get your own pipeline and now
they're like well it's leverage now well
have we ever entertained the possibility
that by then might be a kremlin agent
i haven't actually no no and that one
actually makes the most sense which is
funny
you know hey not that i think it makes
sense
he's pressuring ukraine to cede
territory to the russians i mean come on
if trump did that everybody would be
losing their minds that'd be front page
news on everything nobody's talking
about it nope
it's not even leading this show not to
obviously we we didn't talk about it we
left this weekend evan you think he did
it just to be like
was his intention like hey ukraine don't
get involved in a hot war with russia
just give yeah that was his intention
yeah basically
do you believe that's what it seems like
his intention would be on the surface
but
what if what if putin actually has
compromat on biden and he's had it the
whole time
you know he's tape is real but it's
biden not true
it's probably hunter
no no no no no the p tape for those
aren't familiar was it donald trump at a
hotel yeah in russia what did he do he
peed on the bed no no no he paid women
to
uh release their liquids on to him
i told my mom this was going to be a
halal shot
hey i'm using family-friendly language
here yeah here see that was a
manipulation they the establishment
wanted to run joe biden they knew they
were going to be up against these rumors
so they took control of the narrative
the real story is there is a p-tape it
is not of trump it is of biden and it's
not it's not women of the night it's
that but it is old and incontinent and
was sitting in the bed he went
and someone got it on camera
hey look he who is without peeing their
bed casts the first stone
i think every every person at some point
in their life
just give over to it you ever have a
dream where you're peeing in your dream
and then you wake up and you're actually
peeing no i mean maybe i say that out
loud
it happened i think maybe when i was a
little kid yeah yeah that's what i meant
when i was a kid
not last week
not last week
i don't know man um how do we pivot from
that yeah
ukraine came up and then you know joe
biden's seeding territory to the
russians
that that was like food prices yeah we
were on food yeah let's talk food
well yeah man um i thought inflation was
a good thing
cnn didn't didn't you have more money
didn't cnn write that inflation was a
good thing yeah yeah i think the
intercept also i think you have like
that that pissed me off yeah bloomberg
is good yeah there was a twitter thread
that i highlighted today it was actually
i saw uh
um
i saw somebody retweet this thread where
a guy basically says
right you know average people middle
class people poor people don't
understand what it like what it's like
being rich
and they assume
they assume a lot of things about rich
people now the funny thing is i
certainly think the guy was like i would
i wish poor people could spend a day in
the shoes of a rich person so they could
understand and i'm like dude being rich
is great being poor sucks
however you ever watch trading places
but but
it it is partly true what he was
basically saying is that the world is
made for average people not for rich
people
and
regular people have this assumption that
rich people can do things they can't do
they can just like get whatever they
want so this is what really bothered me
about um
well this is a good context in relation
to the intercept article the intercept
article talking about inflation when
people can't afford to eat was like the
rich people hate inflation and i'm just
like no they don't they can exploit it
very easily without question they can
exploit inflation you buy a piece of
property the property spikes when
inflation hits and then you sell it
later and you kept your money you didn't
lose any buying power a poor person they
they they can't buy property so they get
a paycheck and then it's just worth 10
percent less you know you know when they
put in their savings
but it is true and it's important to
point out
people in this country don't understand
how finance laws work they don't
understand how money works so they get
they get screwed over by the likes of
the intercept they get screwed over by
the likes of cnn but the weirdest thing
is what if how does someone read cnn
and see inflation is good as an op-ed
and then read food is more expensive
than it has been and it's hurting people
and just be like i'm gonna keep reading
this publication
like they told me two different things
but you know whatever
you know some people just want to be
they want to have their biases confirmed
and
these news publications the corporate
media will just continue to feed them
that dribble even if it works against
their own self-interest
and at the point it's like it's like uh
you know the glutton that you keep
feeding it and they're killing
themselves i was just gonna say drugs
there's probably a lot of drug addicts
out there who don't know and have any
common sense or sense of reality and
they're just blindly gazed at cnn with
their mouth drooling open and then you
know just just losing iq points as they
they engage more in that dribble and
absolute nonsense because there's no way
to see the real life ramifications of
inflation and then to think that it's
okay inflation of course first affects
the most poorest people since of course
common goods go up that are mostly
readily available for everyone um and
then of course later down online it
impacts a lot of other people thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time